wir haben euch was ich schon immer
wissen wollte was es eigentlich die
schönste sprache der welt
ja ich denke immer noch französisch
ehrlich gesagt und dann die italienisch
spanisch zu diesem roman i sierte
sprachen sind echt bis heute wunder
stellen und englisch englisch hat eine
und deutsch englisch und deutsch hat so
eine innere schönheit die man erst
später erkennt ja das ist nicht einfach
nur die sparen die du kennst dann müsste
aber wohl nicht mit dabei sein und es
ist nicht wie kenner man muss wahrlich
gut kennen um diese schönheit zu
erkennen so und was machen wir jetzt
heute in dem video
heute fragen wir die menschen welche
ihre meinung nach sprache ist die
schönste in der ganzen welt respekt du
danke sehr
und los geht's
welche sprache deine meinung nach ist
die schönste in der ganzen welt arabisch
das ist in diesem jahr würde ich auch
sagen arabisch französisch und warum
weil sie unfassbar sexy und
energetisches und sprichst du kannst du
dich ich habe in der schule französisch
gelernt und ich kann nur noch ein satz
sprechen willst du den höheren aber der
ist nicht jugendfrei wurde wird er nicht
mehr ja französisch und warum weil sie
so schön klingt höchstgrenze sich ich
habe es in der schule gelernt aber es
ist sehr eingestaubt vermutlich englisch
wolltest du viele können und wolle man
wenn man wenn einem das wort nicht
einfällt dann kann man es einfach
umschreiben
meine meinung nach schon ist sprache ist
heute gehe ich ja welche sprache ist
deine meinung nach die schönste in der
in die welt ja also ich es ist eine
schwierige fragen zu beantworten
ich finde dort sehr gut also es hört
sich gut an sehr intelligent an also für
eine englischsprachige person
ich bin da auch novi sad schön ich habe
es auch gelernt dass ich in norwegen
gebot habe die schönste sprache muss
logisch sein
es ist dem norwegisches wirklich stellen
er wirklich ist richtig schön
französisch oder arabisch spanisch
italienisch besser ich finde es
tatsächlich einen schönsten spanisch
genau und selber sprechen tue ich
eigentlich nur englisch und deutsch auch
mal französisch in der schule gemacht
aber nicht mehr viel los so viele die
vielfalt der sprachen
das ist die schönste sprache der ganzen
welt da kann ich ihnen nur beipflichten
ja das denke ich auch meiner meinung wer
ist die schönste sprache portugiesisch
hieß es ja ich bin dann eher senegalese
sondern vielfach afrikaner ist auf jeden
fall geschwungene it again
ich kann leider kein italienisch das ist
ja so oft leute sagen lebens irgendwann
italienisch zu können und das ist schön
oder slow und italienische kultur ist im
gegensatz zu ihre wirtschaft glaube aber
die kultur ist unglauben und haben sie
beruflich zu tun mit denen sprachen mir
solls fotograf ist es immer ganz
praktisch wenn man verschiedene sprachen
kann auch wenn man reist insofern also
eigentlich schon englisch ist vielleicht
auch in berlin so müssen die dass die
zweite general sprache war ich mal wie
kommt es dass ihr kontakt mit der
sprache und einfach nur was man so hört
und ich spreche kein arabisch verstehen
nur ganz ganz bisschen und ich glaube
dass noch so ein bisschen was mystisches
für mich drum herum sonst hätte man
vielleicht gesagt französisch aber ich
kenne die sprache und das land und
seitdem ist es für mich nicht geschützt
also irgendwie wer tunesien für sie
wahrscheinlich das perfekteste
französischer kolonialisierung und so
kommen sie zu der sprache
ich habe mir lief's studies studiert und
habe auch arabisch angefangen zu lernen
und
hab auch im namen aus den verschiedenen
ländern gelebt bin viel gereist und
deswegen ja und warum findest du schwein
ist schön vom klang her
die ganze nation installation ja sehr
schön ich mache auch zuzuhören wenn
leute spanien sprechen ja es klingt
einfach toll und die irgendwie den
meisten fällen sind das leute mit denen
du gerne abhängen würde ja klar das
macht die schönheit der arabischen
sprache aus ich finde der klang ist zwar
schon hart manchmal aber es irgendwie
auch sehr schön und dann die art und
weise wie man sich im arabischen
ausdrückt finde ich ist sehr sehr
bildlich und poetisch und natürlich die
schrift ist superschön 8 grad wenn man
so richtung kalligraphie geht und so es
ist sehr schön
welche sprache deine meinung nach ist
die schönste in der ganzen welt
französisch frankreich komme muss ich
mag ich sehr gerne die französische und
warum weil der klang sehr gut gehen
die klangfarbe des und die stimme das
hört sich alles sehr gut an und sprechen
sich fremd zu sich leider nein
und haben sie vor französisch zu lernen
ja ich muss das sogar glaube ich mein
sohn ist halber franzose
das ist ja toll deutsches auf jeden fall
nicht die schönste sprache bestimmt
obwohl ich lebe schon 35 in deutschland
und ich habe gelernt das zu mögen
besonders aber trotzdem ist es nicht so
wie du dich
spanisch ist auch sehr schön bei also
bei leader klingt das ist richtig gut
wenn es auf spanisch ist gracias a la
vida kanada die tante und warum spaß ist
der romantische sprache ist und voller
liebe und emotionen also sehr emotionale
sprache sehr lebendige er ich mag er die
entspanntere version die es auch sehr
romantisch und auch sehr liebevoll und
vereinigt genau italo pop bis schlager
sehr cool und ich finde noch mal dass
die italiener vielleicht also dass das
eine sprachlich das leben so ein
bisschen mehr genießt als dass man so
schnell spricht wie beim spanischen dass
er schnell und lernst du spanisch
hatte ich mal vor aber noch nicht ich
mag halt so dieses latino und musik und
so dieses lebendige ich glaube du bist
ja so ein bisschen entspannter deswegen
was eigentlich italienisch und spanisch
gehört was ist ein kontakt mit ihr
sprach bosnien mexiko den sport und das
ist auch unsere vossloh hast du unsere
stadt deshalb bin ich dass mit dieser
sprache und du sprichst aber auch sehr
schön wie kommst du aus der schweiz ja
liebe
die haben mich ist das nicht so dass
eigentlich alles sprachen schön sind und
die menschen nur das nennen womit sie
gerade so in kontakt kommen hier in
europa das beweist unser episode quasi
es gibt aber auch leute die die sprache
gar nicht sprechen und nicht lernen und
trotzdem zum beispiel sagen das
italienisch die schönste sprache ist und
wahrscheinlich liegt das mit dem an der
melodie der sprache und an den
italienischen songs
so und jetzt lieber dann schreibt uns
mal eure meinung in die kommentare was
ist eure lieblings sprache was ist für
euch die schönste sprache der welt
lernte sie oder findet nicht einfach nur
schön anzuhören
hier gehen eure kommentare hin und ihr
könnt ihr es noch ein mitglied werden
von easy german und dann bekommt ihr
interaktive übungen
wir haben schon 1700 mitglieder von the
german und für einen dollar pro woche
seid ihr dabei hier könnt ihr
draufklicken da geht es direkt zu
unserem mitgliederbereich und dann
kriegt ihr jede woche tolle extras wie
viele interaktive übungen tschüss bis
bald und bis zum mittwoch lassen sie was
trinken gehen
was witzig